[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
reggie miller the hall of famer
on the call tonight at the garden with
marv albert game five
hawks in the knicks it's 7 30 eastern
and uh could potentially be marv's last
game ever
at madison square garden with that
wonderful career of his we'll talk about
that match-up
coming up but we uh welcome in reg and
we start with the lakers
yep how would you sum up the position
that they're in right now reg
first of all the the lakers treated
that game five like it was a preseason
game
and that's sad i'm disappointed that
the lakers uh the reigning champs
i know they're down in all-star i know
they're down a top ten player
but other than the first five to seven
minutes
when they showed a little bit of life
they treated that like it was a
preseason game
and obviously you just can't give
playoff games away and they absolutely
just gave a game away
i give credit to phoenix they probably
played their best game
of the series shooting the ball wise
from everyone
but you just can't give games away and
look they're facing a big hole can they
come back and win this series
absolutely but they've got to take it
there's got to be a sense of urgency i
didn't see
any sense of urgency whatsoever in the
lakers last night
but how do they get to a point where
they treat it like it's a pre-season
game like
just this hey we're going to give you
this win we want to go back home and
hopefully we get anthony davis i mean is
did is that how they viewed this game i
think
that's exactly how they viewed it we
have reinforcements coming back
knock on wood but people need to
understand
there's two things that are very
difficult to play with in the game of
basketball a growing injury
very difficult because that's your
lateral movement and back injuries
because you know everything is done your
back controls just about everything
and i'm sure it was very difficult
decision for 80 not to play last night
um but the lakers played like okay
we'll we'll give you guys this game
we'll get a
what 80 a.d back when at home
and then we'll take our chances here in
game seven
where we won uh in this place in game
two
they're putting all their eggs in one
basket assuming that they can win two
games in a row
and they are messing with fire because
chris paul is hungry he wants to beat
his good friend
lebron james devin booker this is his
first time in the playoffs and he wants
to show the world
why he's one of the best shooting guards
on the planet and this young team is
getting confidence
along the way and that's why you're
messing with fire because
they've gained their confidence which
was kind of snatched from them early on
with the chris paul injury
and the way devin booker he hadn't
played particularly great in this series
had a monster game uh one and played
great last night but they have
confidence now and they feel that
they're the better team even though
they're the number two seed they feel
that they're the better team now
lakers are in real trouble what do you
make of charles barkley's nickname for
anthony davis
which i didn't hear what it was oh uh
seton will you play it for reg
anthony davis uh i told you the lakers
can't win this
this this this series forget about the
championship
they can't win this series without uh
street clothes
i'm not even look
i will say this it takes a lot
not to play the game of basketball
especially in the playoffs and
i missed i think in my career and see
you can go back and look at this i
missed four playoff games and i believe
it was in 96
a week before the playoffs were to begin
otis thorpe
broke my orbital fracture i broke my
bone in my he gave me a good fist to the
eye going for a loose ball
and i was out and in that first round
matchup
it was us versus atlanta and
uh i think i was 10 days out from the
surgery
still seeing double vision and i wanted
to play
but there was no way i just knew
but i said i can't i keep telling people
that me at 70
80 is better than a lot of people at 100
percent
and again i know growing injuries are
very difficult to play through
but sometimes just your mere presence
can
uplift your teammates and
i mean a.d is right and he said this
after game one when he played terrible
and had those
13 or 15 points we're not going to win a
game
let alone a series if i continue to play
like that
so again all the eggs are in one basket
for the lakers they're hoping ad comes
back
at 80 percent 70
and they can win two games in a row but
i like the nickname street clothes
i probably went with can get right but
we'll find out how about david davis
anthony david davis not bad
not bad yeah i know everyone wants to
throw shots again
growing injuries are very difficult if
he could play he could play
it's just we've seen this from a.d
i know he's a champion but any little
bump he goes down
and you've got to learn how to play and
manage with injuries that's just a part
of the game everyone at this point in
time of the season
something's ailing on them so
you have any problem with lebron
checking out with five minutes to go
going to the locker room
no but they're down 35 yeah what they're
gonna make a miraculous comeback
i know but do you stay there with your
team
no let me admit maybe something's ailing
on him he's going to go get ice on
something
lebron is the best shot for them to move
on so maybe something
that ankle probably got sore
let me go put it in a bucket of ice and
let me shift all my focus into game six
i have no problem
there's no need for him to be out there
and see that bloodbath he lived it for
about 30 minutes
you know when the baton is passed here
reg from
lebron to who like who gets that well
people assume it's going to be a.d but
they're the lakers
i'm sure there will be another superstar
on the way here
it'll be a.d because there's a pecking
line and he does have a championship
no the the leader the league not the
lakers the like the face of the league
is
is who after lebron
luca i would throw lucas name out there
um i mean you
you you would think it'd be kevin durant
yeah
i mean he's the to me the next best
player if not the best player
uh you know joel b has a great
personality
i mean you need guys that can push the
league
and find those viewers that are just
casual viewers
well lebron's polarizing yeah i don't
know if anybody kind of fits
into that category where you go oh i'm
going to tune in because i want to watch
him lose
or i'm going to tune in because i want
to see you know him win or see greatness
i mean i would put steph in there but
steph was 32-33 so he's obvious you know
i'm talking about the 20 year olds
damien lillard what he did last night i
mean
i he should be a household name which i
he is a household name for
the hardcore basketball fans but for
casual fans
playing in the northwest in portland not
the casual fairing
they may have heard of damian lilly but
they don't really know damien lillard
because
he hasn't really gone deep in the
playoffs like steph or lebron
what would you do if you're damian
lillard i mean
you you're we're going to look back on
your career and go hall of famer
unbelievable nights but is there really
a bottom line exclamation point with
damian lillard
stop it dan because that's that's me
you can't fault a guy for being loyal
you know we kill guys
about championships and then we kill
guys
when kate kevin durant leaves oklahoma
city and goes to golden state
we kill them you know and the small
markets
they can't compete with the chicagos the
new yorks the las
the golden states so when you get a
chance to have
an anthony davis in new orleans you just
pray and hope that
other teams and big markets don't come
recruiting
so we can't look back at lillard's
career and say oh i wish he would have
played in a bigger market
there's nothing wrong with being loyal
and you know people can say well you
never won a championship right yeah i
didn't but
sometimes the whole point of
it's in the struggle and that's what
lillard is in right now he's in the
struggle of
of trying to make a small market team
relevant and successful yeah but i feel
bad for him it's it's not that i'm gonna
go
okay well then frame it that way don't
frame it as in oh we're gonna look back
at your career meant nothing
it did well he's gonna be a hall of
famer i'm just saying we're gonna look
back and say
it's like mike trout we're gonna look
back on mike trout
or dan marino we're gonna go gosh did
they surround him with the right people
that's the point i'm making with damian
i'm not saying he should say get me out
of here but like what can he do
what's his franchise do now it just
feels like there's a glass ceiling
well you hope the franchise and the
leadership of the franchise
says look we got to get some guys around
him look
he is surrounded by some pretty good
players but these had some bad luck as
well
nurkic missed a ton of games this year
mccullum missed a ton of games this year
should they have been a six seat
probably not they should have been a top
four seed if those two guys
play 80 percent of their games but they
didn't
zach collins missed all year i mean
that's a seven footer that can
you know help things you know help help
them out
but look he's doing everything he
possibly can do
and i applaud that for a small market
we're talking to reggie miller the hall
of famer reg's on the call tonight
the knicks in the hawks this must-see tv
yes um well any game you do is must see
tv of course
but uh how do you think the knicks
the knicks fans treat trey young when he
walks in
well well if games one or two were in
the
any indications you saw kind of the
vitriol that was being
thrown at at trey look he's become the
new poster boy here
and i think he has relished and accepted
but i will say this there's certain guys
that are built for it
and i think he wants the moment he
understands
um if they have a chance to move on here
but it is going to be a very
very intense game because the the knicks
have not played great they have not shot
the ball particularly great
their best player
we talk about this you and i all the
time talk about playoff basketball
how things get taken away julius randle
has been
exposed a little bit in this game great
regular season most improved player
which he won but come playoff time when
teams get a chance to scout you
they watch videotape of you they always
take away
your three best plays well what do you
have left in your bag
and right now we're seeing that there's
not a lot of left in the bag so he has
to play very
better rj barrett has to play better
you can't have and god bless him because
to this day he's my favorite player and
i've said this when he was at the height
of his power
when he went through the depths of all
his injuries derrick rose cannot be your
best player
in these playoffs which he has been for
the knicks yeah
you know he he just can't beat your best
player
and barrett randall
that youth they've got to show up which
i think they will i think they win
uh tonight here and they force the game
six
you were on the call with the russell
westbrook situation with
uh the wizards and 76ers and of course i
don't know if in your mind
in the moment you're thinking about the
malice and the palace um
because you were knee-deep in that as
well
and had a front-row seat to that but um
is it fans or fan that we have to be
concerned about here
well isn't that almost one in the same
well
it could be one person like i don't know
the building i don't know if if
there's certain buildings where you go
it's just that's a bad
situation to go into or you have some
idiot who wants to run on the floor and
tap the backboard
like i will say but here's the thing
that idiot did not come to that game
alone
that idiot had to have discussions with
whoever he came to that game
he didn't just get up in the middle of
the game and said look around
and just run out there he had to have
discussions
that he was going to do this i just
think it's unfortunate
now that we've we've finally gotten the
energy back in the buildings by letting
fans back in
that we've had these incidents occur
and i i'm just telling you
if roles were reversed if kyrie had run
up into the stands
and punched that guy wearing the kevin
garnett jersey
i mean all hell would be breaking loose
on networks like this on shows and
podcasts like this
the league has to do a better job what
is banning
a fan from an arena i don't understand
what that
what that entails you can't tell me
that that fan can't get a ticket from a
secondary person and show up in that
building
how are you ever going to know if he's
in that building or not banned from it
what does that mean
no you need you got to go after their
wallets
name these guys put their faces
everywhere like you would do the players
find out where they work you have to go
after their wallets
prosecute them that's how you make it
hurt banning them from an arena what
does that do what does that mean
if i'm banned from arena and you and i
want to go see the next play
i said hey dan just go buy the tickets
and i'll go with you i'll put a hat on
i'll put a fake how are they ever gonna
know other than i'm six seven
well you know that the trey young
situation where
somebody would spit on you that in
today's age of coving
right and i know we're on our way out of
this thing
but to actually spit that what are you
thinking of
that is disgusting seriously i mean it's
sad
and and you know you're i'm asking a 22
year old to be the bigger man here
and trey wasn't going to press charges
but
you know it's just sad has he ever been
named do we know who that person is do
they ever show him
see that's the point if trey won trey
young would have turned around
and knocked that dude out yeah it would
be on a loop i know
i know that would be on a loop i don't
know how you guys and the nba
is different than any other sport
because those fans can actually touch
you
like when you're out of bounds throwing
the ball inbounds i could reach out and
touch you yes they can say things
they can throw things you hear
everything there
i don't know and i will also say this
fans
and i i hope this happens i i i think
we're better than this
they need to start policing each other
too fans need to start policing one
another
no you got you can't say that cut that
out
or usher come get this guy he he is
saying and doing things that are
inappropriate
they need to start policing themselves
are you going to walk around new york
are you okay with walking around new
york
i'm thinking about going out to getting
a late breakfast here
i'm staying somewhere you guys know this
area well is it called the hudson yards
oh yeah oh yeah okay we're staying down
by the hudson yards
nice area so i think i think i can go
out
yeah i think i'm going to try and go out
for a late lunch
okay the good thing about it is everyone
has to wear face
coverings now so they won't know who i
am until after
them so i'm kind of good why don't you
wear
why don't you wear your pacer warm-ups
and just
walk out do a funny or die where you
just walk around and just
like like people's reaction go to a
local court
okay that'd be pretty funny like i think
i did see a basketball court somewhere
around here and guys playing i might
just go show up
to see if anyone wants to play any horse
but do you think it'll be like barkley
in that commercial for capital one where
he's he's not gonna he's not sure if
he's gonna be the first draft pick
with those little kids like what happens
if you go out there
and then you're not the first pick i
would be devastated
don't you know who i am i'm the nick
killer
yeah there is
it's me do you remember i was on your
wall when i was
when you were a kid do you get booed in
the garden will you get booed tonight oh
they're gonna kill me they are going to
kill me and i'm going to
love it i am going to actually love it
but look
i'm more excited to be working alongside
the
that's why i'm doing this game this is
all about marv i can care less about
what the fans are going to say to me
i want him to have potentially this
could be his last game of the garden
i want him to have a great send-off
because this has been
the greatest play-by-play man this game
has ever seen
he worked for the knicks i think he
deserves a great send-off
and that's why they have sent in the the
heavy guns
to do this game so i'm excited about it
27 years ago
yesterday you know what you did against
the knicks
i hope you won a game you had 25 in the
fourth quarter
that was that game that was the choke
sign that was the
spike lead choke sign that's where it
all started
39 points no turnovers
because i wasn't gonna pass the ball
anymore that's why there was no
turnovers
who do you want me to pass it to sal
thompson no sam mitchell
no who am i gonna pass the wall to
god come to think of it you didn't have
any shooters on that you were the only
shooter
i was the only one yes but we had a
squad though my davis boys rick schmitz
we were ready we were ready it was it
was a magical time because we had
two cities that didn't really like one
another that hated one another
yeah uh two coaches that didn't get
along and pat riley and larry brown they
didn't get along
and it kind of filtered down to the
players loved john starks now but
couldn't stand them
charles oakley was a great friend of
mine that couldn't stand him
during those series so do you remember
you threw the ball at the end of the
game threw it down
spiked it and it goes into the stands
damn i wish i held on to that ball
you know paulie see if you can find that
basketball for wrenching
okay on
ebay somewhere somewhere uh reds is on
the call tonight that'll be 7 30 eastern
on tnt
it's the knicks and the hawks red's
great appearance uh
have fun tonight we'll be watching
thanks for joining us i appreciate
theodore dance
after this play of the day dan patrick
show